مع تكدس النازحين والمواطنين داخل المراكز
التي تتبع المؤسسات الدوليه لجا المواطنون
لانشاء خيام في هذه الساحات الفارغه من
اجل ان ياوا اليها في ظل تصاعد العدوان
الاسرائيلي على المواطنين في قطاع غزه
احنا هنا في منطقه تعد منطقه المواصي تم
استهداف بيتنا بالمقابل بيت نا بالمقابل
نا هنا وتم طبعا في تقريبا سته شهداء
استشهدوا واحنا الخيمه تبعتنا ادمرت كلها
اللي هي المفروض اويه هنا خمسه او 26 فرد
هنا موجود عننا هنا ما بين شيوخ وما بين
اطفال وما بين رجال وما بين مسنين وحالات
خاصه تصابوا عنا اربعه من الاطفال ما بين
غرز تقريبا خمسه وسته وسبع غرز الحاله
الشديده كانت عننا هنا طفله صغيره بنت
اخويا ايمن تعرضت لقطع في العصب وقطع في
الشريان وقطع الميض للرجل جينا من غزه
واحن عملنا خيمه وقعدنا فيها طلعنا بره
مولع نار نعمل اكل ل هو صاروخ زنانه اجا
على الدار هذا
وقصفت وطرنا هناك ورا الخيمه
صوبنا
و صوبنا هناك انا تصوت في رجلي وما صوت في
ظهرها وتصور اب يوسف ومحمد علي
وبراء وبابا
وليان تحركت والعصب عندي
فالي
الميه
روح خلصتوا
البندوره هذه الخيمه هذه المتواضعه هذه
قلت لك انا بس تقوينا بس هيك ما نقعدش في
الشارع بس ما نقعدش في الشارع عشان خاطر
بس نضب الحريم عنا معاناه احنا سواء في
الميه في الماكل في المشرب حتى اقوللك
الصرف الصحي كذا احنا بنسحب عن بروح على
حمامات عامه تنظر بعينك هيك انت طابور ما
يقارب 150 نفر عشان يصلك الدور ولا 100
نفر لهلبت ه النار
لهلبت في الليل بقول ايو
حححح
بقط عليها راحه مصروف كيلو بندوره 25 شيكل
جبنا وبدنا نحطها اليوم وبدهم ياكلوها هذا
غدا
هول امسك
منيحين ودي نعمه ربنا يديمها بالنعمه
ويحفظها من الوا ايوان صامدين يا حج لاخر
نفس بقول الحمد لله صدين وصابرين ونحتسب
عند الله تعالى وهذا شيء ما بزنا احنا
مؤمنين بعداله قضيتنا وشرعيتها وان شاء
الله ربنا بنصرنا عاجلا ام اجلا ظروف
الماساويه وقاسيه يعيشها النازحون هنا في
خيام تفتقر الى ادنى مقومات العيش فيها
على ديق مساحتها وانعدام سبل الحياه فيها
فهي ايضا لا تقي من برد شتاء يغشى غزه ولا
من نار بطش
الاحتلال لقناه الجزيره اسماعيل ابو عمر
خان يونس جنوب قطاع غزه